salut tout le monde salue fabien ya tout
le monde on n'est pas résolu pour la
partie donc johnny carson petite
italienne
on est à louvain fab on voit on
reconnaît les fenêtres derrière et la
dame 7 ou de nos saumons rouges ou est
ce que tu souhaites viège est ce que tu
vas madonna du chantier tops jupes
sujets classiques et à dégager tous que
bolt sera différent du coup c'est bon je
suis d'avoir détruit ses trois seuls
états d'âme et s'attelle jane le fou
mais tu vas faire justice machin est à
noter que si tu jouais kg cinq pattes
apf s'ajuste à la caisse des 8 juin donc
à baline donc se passe aussi bien qui
rira qui laisse le fou ces quatre ans
prises moi j'imagine qu'on va même
prendre un peu commandes et de
viennoiseries talent en fait je pense
reprendre plus tard sur mars et 6 comme
ça t'es tu veux gagner un tempo s'est
jamais un jour avec b 5 ou des cinq
avant de le prendre
et puis tu es spot qui est des saints
qui vont tuer après 1,4 façon il fallait
prendre parce que sinon au caire données
sur votre toit de son plan donc
finalement il va jouer avec la sica clés
noires voilà le cera un trio dont elle
se fout enfin tu vois ça ressemble autre
chose du coup d'envoi mais souvent
voisins la viennoise 4,5 et c3 c4 des
idées développées le fou en g 5
peut-être le mettant à trois aussi non
pendant le raid sur des six bonus un peu
tranquille mais va jouer avec ti rock tu
pense qu'il peut même jouer avec grand
roque avec les noirs gens fous aussi sa
fille ce geste un grand roque dégage
bon je le sens je tiens en amour c'est
fait d'ailleurs pas fausse histoire
d'éviter petit à petit on verra comment
on s'en sort en défend bien décison
patel des cinq son plein jour présent le
jour où tu joues des cinq as position
souffle à la perte de foot et bien avec
les notes à long terme
avec g5 ariège cinq élèves car tu crois
pas je suis gardien le développement
avant un petit coup de tourner une fois
été froide this way tour des huit c'est
pas mal non
lojiq au bout mais mon retour à des 8 es
tu veux faire dame 3 et puis après on
remarque s'en fiche
f
who's who qui allie 8 the change des
fous avec f5 un jour effet dames 3 quand
même je ronald thomas
de toute façon j'ai dit piège 5 qu'elle
est quelque part mais si mais si
j'aurais jamais joué secours a besoin
d'espoir que les hommes regardent à 7
j'aurais pensé que messi serait un peu
faible à long terme vient de prendre du
cavalier acat un jour et puis je sais
pas qui soient bénis de défendre
soupirant e double langage 3 il est vite
peut-être du krg quatre cavaliers ou fou
g4 ou mad du couloir et tout ça pas mal
moi je parle tête il faut
faut trouver un moyen continue avec les
douars la femme homme et j'aime bien des
coûts de cavale et enfin qui est là
présente sous des pétales b6 en l'air
pour eux mêmes tours la jst dégage tu
fais un g5 et h5 finalement ouais ok des
ateliers c'est sympa je mes trucs à
paris sg 5 bien sûr très compromettants
toujours je dis ça je ne sais pas si sûr
elle regarde un peu de côté complètement
désabusé je pousse l'option est long les
chaises à roulettes à vue il fait des
petits aller-retour cramique déroulée en
arrière ou en avant fait des allers
retours c'est cool c'est un bois dur
mais je vais vous le tournoi à bout moi
je te sacrifies passage aurait pas de
jeu le tournoi échec basque
c'était bien on a des chaises roulantes
poser l'échiquier de droite à
l'échiquier de gauche mais c'est vrai
quoi si tu manques et il prend un
intermédiaire why not
elles sont le dollar reprend just balls
de plus tu n'as pas droit et je suis
trop 8,3 des soldes jumeaux mais roy et
fut peut-être d'un match s'ils souffrent
f6 mais se fait choper le calme est roi
9h41 ça nous regarde a coûté la partie à
côté m'intéresse beaucoup plus que ce
que tu es en train de faire
comprends pas c'est quoi cette pièce
sont plus qualifiés les archers aux
patates en train de se dire fièrement
balancer une pièce je suis chaud pas de
but c'est au tour g8 et à chaque fois
c'est fini 32e mais bon repas comment
t'as même pas un échec pas rien mais
étonnant ce sacrifice à 2 kramix et
c'est complètement nul
ça n'a aucun intérêt des pièces c'est de
la merde en fait je crois qu'il a bien
compris ce principe mais alors après
au niveau mise en place on n'est pas
dans sa tour g8 pour g6 je ne sais pas
faim dam des huit dames g8
enfin abandonne quoi non plus il a l'air
confiant fibernet trotter je calcule des
variantes carlson le soul blues
il souffle mais en train de se dire je
joue un tour inquiets pas du tout à mon
niveau
heureusement dès 21h et récents comme
party by rasoli je pense se rend le mur
beats heures à c'est un bide sert en
fait donc nous sommes meilleurs joueurs
donc ça qui met en plus je pense en
blitz de temps encore que au dessus je
sais pas mais parce qu'il a tout il ya
le calcul est en vie très important de
savoir où placer les pièces parce que
t'as pas le terrible et il a le truc
pour bien placer des pièces finale dames
feeling f4 boucle il est très confiant
cramique like you mais je crois qu'on
peut le prendre ce trou maryja tu prends
vous prendrez way back avec un tee shirt
rose qui aiment passer sur des cheveux
roses le t-shirt multi choix oui j'aime
apprise étrangers six fin j'ai peut-être
que quinzaine il dit non on prend pas
non plus bas malgré cela peut être 100%
idiot fin seul à ses mauvaises traitait
de famille quand même faire un peu gaffe
teinte à des cinq aussi qui peut être tu
est jouable naquit des sur f5 de faire
des 4 tu vois c'est quoi ce tableau en
toile de fond le mont ouais je sais pas
parce que carlson ces deux se demande
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que c'est que
ce tableau socotec rami qui doit zilian
nepomniachi on le voit à droite derrière
la bouteille d'eau c'est à dire je ne
peux pas finir avoriaz j'ai pas le droit
qu'on n'existe pas
[Musique]
quelle est la juste un peu calculer mais
du coup par h2s que sur fou prend 1,7 à
l'ats me prends tu reviens up top qui
égale un f4 basse et ça sent la fin des
haricots
il n'aura pas vraiment fait illusion
dans cette partie dams est très bon coup
dans l'italienne je développe madame en
premier non mais c'est pas c'est pas con
soudano cette suite met reiss est après
de faire si j'ai six ou juste cette rock
d624 ma place comme ça
puis bon caillage 5 kg à 3 tu sais pas
trop
les blancs normalement pas il faut plus
des trucs avec ses trois rivières le fou
ils font tourner un des quatre ils
prennent le centre un buzz comme
toujours mais donc sûrement c'est un
poil mais pour les blancs mais c'est pas
toi ça on le voit rarement on voit plus
toujours ils font tous ou c5
mais c'est pas idiot absurdes comme
système camille grève si beaucoup et
erika la même c'est insolite je crois
que ça donne encore une fois je 4 c'est
bien de plus donc et je prends une
menace en un coup non je sais pas mais
n'importe quel coût engagé cet hiver et
partage retour j'ai cinq femmes ont ces
deux pièces de crise maintenant
peut-être qu'on va finir avant dépôt
c'est pas bien je vois pas je rends
heureux
les grammy qui a l'air d'être
complètement out of forme out of shame
pas rempli ce qui est carrément dingue
c'est qu'il est complètement guéri et en
train et enfin il ya comme un oeuf pour
filer une pièce en un parfait 3,5 et
puis un coup après ce calcul qui est
maintenant à peut-être donné
en fait ce qui est dingue c'est qui
conduit un jeu comme s'il avait encore
de le faire chez miles à deux pièces de
moins à 20 de la déprime une oui mais
bon fallait jarry continue à jouer un
ton qui la font quoi fâcher matin
personne tension qui calcule encore fait
qu'ils se posent des questions ils
balancent la tête
est ce que fout est-ce que je peux mener
une attaque avec une dame seule mais
enfin madame des quatre échecs ou un
petit piège impudemment 5 nous sommes
pense être un pas mal aussi
madame e5 alors âgée de france et 3 t il
le fait marcher ou à non loin de la
bande de fous je sais pas comme j'étais
complètement gagnant je ne comprends pas
coiffage et avait donné deux pièces dans
l'esprit j'ai loupé d'un grand c3 dont
c'est possible tu as vraiment de la
chance mais j'étais beaucoup plus dans
l'esprit que toi d'ailleurs c'est moi
qui ai la partie quand il est allé voir
l'arbitré dit non j'ai donné trois
pièces lui dont il n'aurait pas donné
une seule je ne comprends pas comment on
peut donner la victoire au noir dans
cette partie on va fabien jolie partie
web maîtrise de mag jusque là les chats